et que tout le monde puisse travailler ensemble vers l’égalité réelle.
PM : Je pense que l’un des éléments les plus frappants de votre livre,
et à mon avis, l’une des raisons pour lesquelles il nous a secoués
et qu’il a un écho dans le monde entier, est que vous y êtes personnelle.
Vous précisez bien que, même si vous avez observé certaines choses
très importantes à connaître pour les autres femmes,
vous avez eu les mêmes difficultés que beaucoup d’autres,
en faisant face aux obstacles et aux barrières et éventuellement,
aux personnes qui ne pensent pas comme vous.
Parlons maintenant de ce processus : parler en public de sa vie privée,
et se placer en position d’expert sur la façon de résoudre ces difficultés.
SS : Après avoir donné la conférence TED, ce qui m’est arrivé a été…
Vous savez, je ne me suis jamais vraiment imaginée écrire un livre,
je ne suis pas auteure, je ne suis pas écrivain.
La conférence a beaucoup été vue et elle a vraiment commencé
à avoir un impact sur la vie des gens. J’ai eu ce grand…
L’une des premières lettres reçues était celle d'une femme
écrivant qu’on lui a offert une promotion vraiment très importante au travail,
qu’elle a refusée. Quand elle l’a raconté à sa meilleure amie,
celle-ci a dit : « Tu as vraiment besoin de visionner cette conférence TED. »
Elle la regarda, et le lendemain, elle accepta le poste,
elle rentra chez elle et elle confia la liste des courses à son mari.
(Rires) Elle s'est dit : j’en suis capable.
Ce qui est vraiment important pour moi, c'est que ce n’était pas seulement destiné
aux femmes du monde de l’entreprise, même si j’ai entendu parler de beaucoup
d’entre elles et que cela a eu un impact sur bon nombre d’entre elles,
il s’agissait aussi de femmes dans toute sorte de circonstances.
J’ai rencontré un médecin à Johns Hopkins, disant qu'avant d'avoir vu ma conférence,
il n’avait jamais vraiment remarqué que même si la moitié des élèves
dans ses cours de médecine étaient des femmes,
elles ne parlaient pas autant que les hommes pendant ses visites.
Il a commencé à faire attention, et quand qu’il attendait que les mains se lèvent,
il comprit qu’il n’y avait que des mains d’homme levées.
Il a commencé à encourager les femmes à plus lever la main
mais cela ne fonctionnait toujours pas. Alors il a dit à tout le monde :
« Ne levez plus la main, je vais vous désigner. »
Ainsi, il pouvait appeler également des hommes ou des femmes.
Il s'est prouvé que les femmes connaissaient les réponses aussi bien
voire mieux et il leur fit un commentaire en leur raconta cela.
Il y a eu cette femme, mère au foyer, vivant dans un quartier très difficile,
sans école correcte. Elle n’a jamais travaillé en entreprise,
mais elle a dit que la conférence TED lui a inspiré de revenir vers son école
et de se battre pour que son enfant ait de meilleurs professeurs.
Je suppose que cela m'a permis de trouver ma propre parole.
J’ai réalisé que d'autres pourraient trouver leur parole à travers la mienne,
c’est pourquoi je suis passée de la conférence au livre.
PM : Dans votre livre, vous avez trouvé non seulement votre parole,
claire et forte, mais vous avez aussi partagé ce que vous avez appris
(des expériences des autres). C’est ce que je veux dire par experte,
vous êtes devenue une sorte d’experte de la façon d’aller « En avant toutes ».
Donc, qu’est-ce qui vous a motivé ?
Pour lancer non seulement un livre, mais un best-seller,
la conférence la plus regardée, mais un mouvement où les gens
ont commencé à décrire littéralement leurs actions au travail sous la forme
« En avant toutes ».
SS : Je suis reconnaissante, honorée, je suis heureuse et c’est le tout début.
Je ne sais pas si je suis une experte, ni si quelqu’un l'est.
J’ai certainement fait beaucoup de recherches. J’ai lu toutes les études,
j’ai étudié de près les documents et les leçons sont très claires.
Voici ce que nous savons :
Partout, les stéréotypes éloignent les femmes des rôles de leadership
C’est si frappant. « En avant toutes » est très global,
j’ai été partout pour en parler et, les cultures sont tellement différentes.
Même dans notre pays, au Japon, en Corée, en Chine, en Asie, en Europe,
elles sont si différentes. Sauf sur une chose : l’égalité des sexes.
Partout dans le monde, quelles que soient nos cultures, nous pensons que les hommes
doivent être forts, autoritaires, agressifs, prendre la parole ;
que les femmes ne doivent parler que lorsqu'on les y autorise,
qu'elles doivent aider les autres. Dans le monde entier, certaines
femmes sont dites « autoritaires ». Dans toutes les langues,
une expression existe qui signifie « autoritaire » pour les petites filles.
Elle n’est presque pas utilisée pour les petits garçons,
parce que quand un petit garçon dirige, il n’y a aucun mot négatif pour ça,
c’est ce qui est attendu. Mais quand une petite fille dirige,
c’est une « Mademoiselle J’ordonne ».
Maintenant, je sais qu’il n’y a pas beaucoup d’hommes ici,
mais restez avec moi. Quand vous êtes un homme, vous devez représenter votre sexe.
Merci de lever la main si on vous a dit que vous êtes trop agressif au travail.
(Rires) Il y en a toujours quelques-uns, qui représentent environ 5%. Mesdames,
merci de lever la main si on vous a dit que vous êtes trop agressive au travail.
(Rires) C’est ce que le public a répondu dans tous les pays du monde,
et c’est fortement étayé par les données. Maintenant, pensons-nous que les femmes
soient plus agressives que les hommes ? Bien sûr que non.
C’est juste que nous les jugeons à travers un filtre différent.
Beaucoup des traits de caractère dont il faut faire preuve pour réussir au travail,
pour obtenir des résultats, pour diriger, sont ceux desquels nous pensons,
chez les hommes, « C’est un chef », chez les femmes, « Elle est autoritaire ».
La bonne nouvelle, c’est que nous pouvons changer cela en le reconnaissant.
L’un des moments les plus heureux de ce parcours fut, après la sortie du livre,
lorsque je me suis trouvée sur scène avec John Chambers, le PDG de Cisco.
Il avait lu le livre et se tenait sur scène, il m’avait invitée devant son équipe
dirigeante entière, hommes et femmes.
Il a regretté : « Je pensai que nous étions justes. Je pensai que je l'étais.
Puis j’ai lu ce livre, et j’ai réalisé que nous (mon entreprise) avions jugé
toutes nos femmes aînées comme trop agressives, je m'en excuse devant vous.
Je veux que vous sachiez que nous ne recommencerons jamais. »
PM : Peut-on raconter cela à tout le monde ?
(Applaudissements)
SS : Il s’est excusé parce qu’il croit que c’est bon pour son entreprise.
Ce genre de reconnaissance des disparités peut les changer.
La prochaine fois que vous verrez quelqu’un appeler une petite fille
« Mademoiselle J’ordonne », vous marcherez vers cette personne,
grand sourire et vous direz : « Cette fillette n’est pas autoritaire.
Elle a des compétences de dirigeante. » (Rires)
Je suis sûre que c'est ce que vous dites à votre fille !
SS : Absolument.
PM : Le but de votre livre était de créer un dialogue à ce sujet,
comme vous l’avez dit : faisons face au fait que les femmes,
alors qu’elles ont plus de portes ouvertes et d’occasions,
n’obtiennent toujours pas de positions de leadership.
« En avant toutes » y est consacré et il présente quelques-uns des défis restants,
que nous devons résoudre par et en nous-mêmes.
Qu’y a-t'il de changé depuis sa parution ? Avez-vous vu des changements ?
SS : Il y a certainement plus de dialogue, ce qui est très bien.
Ce qui compte vraiment pour moi, je crois pour nous tous, c’est l’action.
Partout où que je vais, les dirigeants pour la plupart des hommes, me disent :
« Vous me coûtez si cher : les femmes veulent être payées
autant que les hommes. »
Je leur réponds que je ne regrette rien. (Rires) Rien du tout.
Je veux dire, les femmes devraient être payées autant que les hommes.
Partout, les femmes me disent qu’elles demandent des augmentations,
qu’elles ont de meilleures relations avec leur conjoint,
en leur demandant plus d’aide à la maison, en réclamant les promotions
qu’elles devraient obtenir au travail et ce qui est important,
en croyant en elles. Même pour de petites choses.
Le gouverneur de l’un des États m’a dit qu’il n’avait pas réalisé
que plus de femmes se mettaient littéralement de côté dans leur salle.
Il a maintenant établi une règle pour que toutes les femmes
de son équipe s’assoient à la table.
La base, posée avec « En avant toutes », aide les femmes, ou les hommes,
à commencer des cercles, de petits groupes de 10 ou plus,
qui se réunissent une fois par mois.
J’avais espéré atteindre environ 500 cercles, cela aurait été bien, 500 x 10.
Il y a plus de 12 000 cercles dans 50 pays du monde entier.
PM : C’est incroyable. SS : Et ils se réunissent chaque mois.
J’ai rencontré le premier groupe sur Pékin, un groupe de femmes dans la trentaine.
Plusieurs d’entre elles ont grandi en Chine rurale et très pauvre.
Leur société dit qu’à 29 ans, elles sont « laissées pour compte » car pas mariées.
Se réunir une fois par mois les aide à définir qui elles sont pour elles-mêmes,
ce qu’elles veulent dans leur carrière, le genre de partenaires qu’elles veulent,
Nous nous sommes présentées, elles ont décliné leur nom, leur origine.
J’ai dit : je suis Sheryl Sandberg et ceci était mon rêve.
Je crois que je me suis mise à pleurer. Bon, ok, j’ai pleuré. J’en ai déjà parlé.
Mais le fait qu’une femme si éloignée, qui a grandi dans un village rural,
que l'on force à se marier, puisse aller à une réunion mensuelle,
refuser cela et mener sa vie selon ses propres modalités,
c’est le genre de changement que nous devons souhaiter.
PM : Avez-vous été surprise par la nature globale du message ?
Je crois qu'à la parution du livre, beaucoup ont pensé qu'il s'agissait
d'un guide vraiment important pour les jeunes femmes en progression.
Elles doivent lire ce livre, anticiper les obstacles, les détecter, les sauter,
mais il est destiné à des femmes dans la course au monde de l’entreprise.
Désormais, votre livre est lu dans les pays ruraux et en développement.
Qu’est-ce qui vous a surpris et conduit à un nouveau point de vue ?
SS : Le sujet de mon livre est la confiance en soi et l’égalité.
Il s’avère que, partout, les femmes ont besoin de plus de confiance en elles,
parce que le monde entier nous dit que nous ne sommes pas égales aux hommes.
Nous vivons dans un monde où les hommes obtiennent « et » et les femmes « ou ».
Je ne connais pas d'homme à qui l’on ait demandé comment il arrive à tout faire.
Les hommes : levez la main si on vous a demandé :
« comment arrivez-vous à tout concilier ? » Maintenant les femmes !
Les hommes pourraient tout gérer, un job et des enfants, mais pas les femmes.
C’est ridicule, car la plupart des femmes travaille à temps plein et a des enfants.
On ne perçoit pas complètement l’universalité du message.
Un cercle a démarré avec des prostituées secourues à Miami.
Il utilise « En avant toutes » pour aider ces femmes à revenir vers ce qui serait
une vie juste, en les sauvant vraiment de leurs souteneurs.
Des groupes font fureur au Texas et se basent sur mon livre,
pour des femmes qui n’ont jamais été au lycée.
Nous savons qu’il existe des groupes jusqu’en Éthiopie.
Ainsi ces messages d’inégalité, qui disent aux femmes qu’elles ne peuvent pas obtenir
autant que les hommes où nous supposons que le leadership
est pour les hommes, comme la parole, nous affectent tous
et je pense qu’ils sont très universels. L'action de TEDWomen est de rassembler
autour d'une cause à laquelle nous devons croire :
« Plus de femmes, plus de prise de parole, plus d’égalité. »
PM : Si vous étiez invitée à donner une autre conférence TEDWomen,
que nous raconteriez-vous comme résultat de cette expérience, pour vous--même,
qu'avez-vous avez appris sur les femmes et les hommes,
SS : Je pense que je dirais, j'ai déjà essayé de le dire,
mais je pense que je peux le dire encore plus fort,
que le statu quo n’est pas suffisant. Que rien ne change assez vite.
Depuis ma première conférence TED et la parution de mon livre,
de nouvelles statistiques ont été publiées par le recensement américain.
Savez-vous ce que nous avons trouvé ?
L’écart salarial entre hommes et femmes aux États-Unis n'a pas bougé.
Soixante-sept cents contre un dollar. Si vous êtes une femme noire, 64 cents.
Pour une Latino, nous sommes à 54 cents. Savez-vous à quand remonte la dernière
augmentation de ces chiffres ? À 200...2 !
Nous sommes en stagnation, nous stagnons à bien des égards.
Nous ne sommes pas vraiment honnêtes à ce propos, pour tellement de raisons.
Il est si difficile de parler d’égalité. Nous avons peur du mot « féministe »,
un mot que nous avons besoin d’adopter, je le pense vraiment.
Je dirais plus fort qu'il faut se débarrasser du mot « autoritaire »
(Applaudissements) et ramener le mot « féministe », car nous en avons besoin.
(Applaudissements) PM : Nous avons besoin aussi d'aller « En avant toutes ».
SS : Beaucoup plus en avant.
PM : Je vous remercie, Sheryl.
Merci d’aller « En avant toutes » et de dire oui.
SS : Merci.
(Applaudissements)